the 8 month long round-the-world race
has reached the finish line and with it
an end to the most comprehensive
research yet on how much plastic is in
the world's oceans samples collected
throughout the 45 thousand mile journey
by the yacht turn the tide on plastic
are still being analyzed but they
revealed traces of micro plastic almost
everywhere including some of the most
remote parts of the planet the
Portuguese Mir Puri foundation like sky
ocean rescue one of the sponsors of the
mission says the findings are
devastating it will be catastrophic not
now but in the third generation each
time more we have this disease new
diseases from new contaminants we are
having more cancer more allergic
diseases more infertility we are less
fertile than our grandfathers are you
saying the plastic is killing the human
race yes is killing human race but
slowly we don't realize how many
chemicals we have in the world that
could interfere with us you just scare
mongering aren't you the way you use
plastic and this is so convenient for
modern life we are not gonna change if
you are not scary other scientists are
more measured in their conclusions but
share the same concerns because micro
plastic is consumed by shellfish which
are then eaten by humans we actually
don't know the extent of the risk at the
moment but I think we can say with some
certainty that if we don't both
understand the problem understand the
scientific challenges there will come a
point whether it be so much plastic in
the ocean that we will be facing hazards
that could be endangering human life
the crew have conducted the research
while at the same time battling
treacherous seas in a highly competitive
race having endured such dangerous
conditions they hope the findings will
indeed turn the tide on pasta I'm proud
to be part of it it gives you a great
sense of achievement and especially when
we get the results back I'm saddened by
the results but at the same time it's
because of us that they have them and
that's that's a great achievement the
event ends in the hague this week but
this research could be a watershed
moment in efforts to clean up the
world's oceans in Woods Sky News